the streets are decorated in traditional
Chinese New Year style the markets in
Victoria Park are central to the busy
and colorful festival plants and flowers
signifying hope and promise for a new
year are on sale but the government has
banned the sale of what are known as dry
goods any items with a political
reference that hasn't stopped
pro-democracy groups holding their own
independent markets because of the
protests and also we think that Hong
Kong people should take more control on
their own freedom and economics so we
plan to set up this market and hopefully
Hong Kong people can have their freedom
on how to how to use their money
basically this is one of the number of
crowdfunded markets being held across
the city called burn fee on sale a
handicrafts and products highlighting
the anti-government message with
stallholders came to reaffirm their
political stance in the past few months
Hong Kong is that is that raising some
problems with police show we want to
deliver some message in the happy a
Chinese failure to let them feel happy
and the products can show the Hong Kong
message they are around 15 independently
organized markets being held over the
Chinese New Year holiday break the
location of some of them is not being
shared perfectly you have to register
first to get those details in the
current climate organisers fear any
politicize event will be targeted by
police security checks are in place
across the main festival locations but
the government isn't taking any chances
the annual fireworks display has been
cancelled so too has the traditional
Chinese New Year parade what was once
considered the most significant festival
of the year in Hong Kong is rather
low-key for 2020 and anti-government
protesters are planning another rally on
Sunday which might further dampen the
celebrations Sarah Clark al Jazeera Hong
Kong